let's go to Lexi from New Mexico Lexi
welcome to the program
and Lexi you've got to unmute yourself
you've currently self-muted
and only if you turn that off will I be
able to hear you
hi David can you hear me yes
sorry I was in the process of making
sure I was completely muted on Discord
so you just beautiful beautiful
um
so I'm a young voter I just turned 18 in
this last June so I got to vote for the
first time beautiful and something I saw
at least here in New Mexico and my
voting basis is
how active especially the older voting
group is just first hand compared to
younger voters and like
um gen xers right
and then seeing in my own classroom and
even in like my parents friends and
everything how so many people still have
the mentality of whatever I do whatever
I vote for it doesn't really affect me
in politics especially when it comes to
National politics so many people just
don't think that their vote matters and
don't really think that anything big is
gonna happen
but I think the reason we've started to
see that change a little bit more with
younger voters is the Republicans
rhetoric where against the lgbtq
community because so many young voters
and young people are part of that
Community yes
um so they I I think it's going to be
hard for Republicans uh going off what
they'll call her a few callers ago uh
was talking about for Republicans to
fully grab onto the younger voting base
because they are pushing that issue so
hard I tend to agree with you I think
unless they ease up a little bit on that
stuff they are going to struggle with
the 18 to 29 year old but not not
necessarily because 18 to 29 year olds
are part of that group but to some
degree because 18 to 29 year olds don't
see it as logical to be attacking
individuals who are lgbtq
yeah because even if they're not part of
that group a lot of them have friends in
that group or they know people in that
group and everything so yeah I agree but
my question is how do you think
Democrats can not only start to mobilize
more younger voters but just all the
people who are a center and Center left
who I know who just don't go and vote
because from my perspective I see that
it's much more likely for the people who
are center right and right to go vote
than the people who are centered left
and left to go vote because Democrats
are just so bad at mobilizing and
motivating voters
I think you're absolutely right you know
I I don't have any special insights on
get out the vote this is a known issue
that get out the vote is tough on 18 to
29 year olds but I think the Instinct
you have is absolutely correct the right
is pouring money into it as I talked
about earlier with another caller and
unless the left starts doing it and
activating people with these glitzy
events and wrestling style intros I hate
to say it but the Wright does some of
that stuff because it works and the left
needs to figure out how to do it listen
Lexi I'm going to let you go because I
am out of time I appreciate everybody
who called in we're going to take a
quick break and be right back
I love cooking at home I cook all the
time having a good set of knives that
you actually like to use is really
important for years I have been a fan of
the advantages that Japanese knives
offer and our sponsor kamikoto makes
amazing Japanese steel kitchen knives
using the traditional techniques that
date back to the Edo period of Japan
kamikoto only uses steel from Japan each
blade takes years to craft and goes
through a rigorous 19-step inspection
process with a lifetime guarantee the
knives come in a beautiful heavy duty
Ash wood box makes it a really great
gift easy to store as well on the
kamikoto website you can see a map of
the Michelin star chefs all over the
world using kamikoto knives my kamikoto
knives at home have been performing
great for years you really just can't
beat the feel of a nice Japanese knife
perfectly balanced in your and and
kamikoto is now running a big Black
Friday sale my audience gets an extra
fifty dollars off go to kamikodo.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman the link
is down below